tja das ist gar kein Aufreger 1 das ist
ein Vergleich den ich machen möchte
heute heute ist Dienstagmorgen ist
Mittwoch das ist kein Wunder aber morgen
wird im Bundeskabinett etwas entschieden
was von großer Bedeutung ist von großer
Reichweite nämlich ein Gesetz in dem
Hartz IV de facto abgeschafft wird und
als Nachfolger des Bürgergeld auf den
Weg gebracht wird das klingt erstmal
wunderbar aber mit dieser Entscheidung
sind einige Dinge hängen damit zusammen
die ein paar Änderungen bedeuten eine
entscheidende Änderung ist dass die
Sätze für Hartz IV dann für das
Bürgergeld deutlich ansteigen wenn man
das einmal durchrechnet dann das ist der
Vergleich kommt man doch auf ganz
interessante Zahlen wir nehmen eine
vierköpfige Familie die von Hartz IV
lebt was bitter genug ist das möchte ich
einmal vorausschicken und stellen fest
dass sie mit ihren hartz-iv-sätzen für
die beiden Ehepartner und die beiden
Kinder auf fast 2000 Euro kommt ungefähr
1700 1800 Euro dann übernimmt der Staat
die Jobcenter die Mietzahlung nehmen wir
mal an 500 Euro dann kommen noch 100
Euro Heizkosten über drauf die auch die
Allgemeinheit übernimmt Sozialbeiträge
werden ebenfalls bezahlt das heißt wir
reden eigentlich über einen Geldbetrag
von rund zweieinhalb Tausend Euro die
dieser Familie von den Beitragszahlern
erstmal zugeschoben wird so und dann
reden wir über Menschen die hart
arbeiten die täglich früh aufstehen ein
Maler beispielsweise der im Durchschnitt
2500 brutto in Deutschland verdient dann
noch Abzüge hat natürlich ganz klar wenn
der Alleinverdiener einer vierköpfigen
Familie ist dann gibt es natürlich auch
noch Kindergeld das ist klar bei der
kommt auf gar nicht so viel mehr als
diese vierköpfige Hartz iv-familie
nehmen wir ein friseurepaar
beispielsweise der Friseur Lohn im
deutschen liegt bei ungefähr 1700 1800
Euro brutto da gibt es wenig Abzüge aber
am Ende muss man sagen diese Menschen
arbeiten wahnsinnig hart müssen ihre
Miete bezahlen müssen die steigenden
Heizkosten selbst bezahlen steigende
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und fragen
mutmaßlich am Ende des Monats wieso habe
ich eigentlich kaum mehr als mein
Nachbar der gar nicht arbeiten geht
deshalb mein großes Plädoyer diese
Reform die da anstieht die muss noch mal
durch den Bundestag die muss noch mal
ordentlich geschüttelt und gerührt
werden den eins ist klar der da arbeitet
darf nicht weniger haben als der der
nicht arbeitet darf nicht der Dumme am
Ende sein Frau Guru würden sie mit
genesin sie das mit dem Bürgergeld also
diese Frage des lohnabstandsniveaus so
haben wir das ja früher diskutiert ist
ja scheinbar eine alte ja also ich
glaube tatsächlich dass es sowieso nicht
schön ist bei auf Hartz hier zu sein
also die Sätze der gezahlt werden sind
offensichtlich ja sowieso sehr sehr sehr
niedrig ja insofern ist schon mal die
Frage wie kann man überhaupt damit
umgehen aber wir können das auch
zurückkoppeln an die Diskussion die wir
hatten wenn wir eine Industrie erhalten
das ist ja im Prinzip ja eigentlich
immer der fdp-talk ja dann haben wir
genug Arbeitsplätze dann haben wir das
Problem der Arbeitslosigkeit nicht dann
haben wir das Hartz IV Probleme offen
also wir haben ich glaube 590.000
Arbeitsplätzen gerade offene Stellen in
Deutschland also es gibt genügend offen
bestellen dass es nicht gerade ist wenn
Probleme den Arbeitsplätzen war die
Arbeitsplätze ist ja immer die Frage
sozusagen wie ist der Arbeitsmarkt und
was sind die offenen Stellen und wie
sind die Qualifizierung für diesen
Arbeitsmarkt ja und dann ist immer das
Frage ist immer die Frage des unteren
Segmentes wo die Leute eben nicht
qualifiziert genug sind und da entstehen
besonders Restaurants suchen gerade alle
besonders also wir haben gerade nicht
das Problem also ich würde sagen wir
sind gerade eher ein Arbeitnehmermarkt
als ein arbeitgebermarkt wenn man sich
die Zahlen der freien Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland anschaut es gibt jetzt sogar
schon ein Bahnhöfen Buchhandlungen die
früher schließen weil sie kein Personal
haben Restaurants die früher dicht
machen ich denke dass man Paket fahre
ich denke dass man gerade doch sagen
muss oder sehen muss die Jobs sind da
wir kriegen die Leute noch nicht rein ja
aber dann ist tatsächlich die Frage und
das muss ja diskutiert werden ja was
sind das für Jobs sie werden sie
bezahlen also ich möchte kein Paketbote
sein ja wir wissen ja aus allen
möglichen Dokumentationen dass diese
Leute fast so unterirdischen Bedingungen
arbeiten
ich will überhaupt gar nicht sondern die
Frage ist wie kriegen wir eine faire
schlechte Gesellschaft in der das nicht
passiert was Sie beschreiben ja also
dass das lohnabstandsniveau nicht
gewahrt ist aber wie kriegen wir Jobs
von denen man leben kann und Jobs die
nicht tatsächlich
die Frage ja eigentlich die Frage ist
wie bekommen wir Leute die arbeiten
können dazu dass sie wirklich arbeiten
weil ehrlich gesagt ich nicht einsehe
warum eigentlich ich Leute
mitfinanzieren soll die Arbeiten könnten
die sagen aber die aber einfach nur
deswegen nicht sich wirklich ernsthaft
um einen Job bemühen oder sagen der Job
ist unter meiner Würde und einfach unser
Geld unser aller Geld nehmen nein doch
doch ne lass nämlich Ausreden ich finde
das ist unsozial das was wir da tun ist
ja unsozial weil erstens mal gibt es
keinen Anreiz sich selbst auch aus
dieser Misere herauszuarbeiten was ja
auch für jeden Menschen glaube ich etwas
ist was auch den den die für die Würde
des Menschen wirklich wichtig ist dass
man sich selbst ernähren kann dass man
nicht abhängig ist von anderen Menschen
das ist eine wichtige Sache und das ist
auch ein gutes also ich sagen wir sehen
auch dass wir ja inzwischen gehen über
generationenübergreifend dass er
weitergereicht wird Eltern die Eltern
die es von Sozialhilfe leben geben
dieses Lebensmodell an ihre Kinder
weiter das heißt wir schaffen ja wir
schaffen Dynastie
also weiter für Sanktionen hier Beispiel
absolut aber ich wir erhöhen gerade wir
sind wir sind quasi eigentlich auf dem
Weg gerade zu einem versteckten
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen und das
ist das falsche Anwalt in Europa immer
stolz darauf gewesen im Unterschied zum
Beispiel zu den Vereinigten Staaten dass
wir hier etwas haben wir ein
Sozialmodell oder sozialmodelle wir
haben immer geredet ganz egal ob es
Gewerkschaftspolitik war in der
Sozialdemokratie auch in der
christlichen Soziallehre dass wir haben
Arbeit haben das ist selbstständig ist
und würde geht aber dass diese Jobs
nicht am Rande der Ausbeutung sind ja
und das Verhandeln wir jetzt hier in
diesem neuen Jobs ich habe eben schon
gesagt der Paketbote wo die
Arbeitsbedingungen und so weiter höchst
fragwürdig sind und die Frage ist ob wir
das anders diskutieren können ich bin
absolut bei ihnen es muss ein
Lohnabstandsgebot geben ich bin absolut
bei ihnen man muss eigentlich selbst
verantwortlich sein Leben arbeiten immer
und das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig
weil sie das auch noch mal sagt man muss
von seiner seinen geflügelter Spruch
erinner Sozialdemokratie man muss von
seiner eigenen Hände Arbeit leben können
ja jetzt muss das ist alles richtig
dieses Land entwickelt sich weiter wir
Arbeiten nicht mehr mit Rauchzeichen
wenn wir irgendwas in die Welt schicken
wollen sondern haben ein ganz moderne
Telefone das bedeutet auch das Löhne
steigen in Jobs an denen man die sehr
produktiv sind wenn ich nichts gelernt
habe das muss man einfach dann auch so
sagen ein Job machen muss den jeder
jeder machen kann weil er keine
Qualifikation bedarf dann kann ich nicht
erwarten dass ich das gleiche verdiene
wie jemand der top ausgebildet ist und
in der Debatte um die Frage man muss von
seiner eigenen Hände Arbeit leben können
muss glaube ich immer die Frage stellen
wenn ihr was hast denn gelernt was hast
du denn gelernt was sich besonders
Chancengerechtigkeit wer kommt noch an
die Schulen wo sind die guten Schulen
und so weiter da sind wir bei ganz
anderen Themen ja und und diese Themen
und diese Themen sind längst da können
Sie doch einmal durch die Republik gehen
da sind die Reichenviertel die
Armenviertel wer hatte das sie haben
arme Menschen die ihre Kinder zur Schule
schicken sie haben arme Menschen die
dafür sorgen dass ihre Kinder ja damit
Sie es mal besser haben ja sie ist
selber haben und sie haben arme Menschen
die sagen so lebt man wunderbar vom
Staat und du musst gar nicht wir hatten
in den 70er Jahren weniger Kinder in
Armut als die Bundesrepublik noch nicht
so reich war wie heute haben wir heute
eigentlich Begriff
ist die Frage haben wir ein
Verteilungsproblem oder Gerechtigkeit
nämlich aus der
bestreiten dass die Ungleichheit
was anderes weil die Menschen auch die
Kinder auch die Kinder der Arme sind
heute absolut erheblich reicher als in
den 70er Jahren das ergibt sich nur aus
dem relativen Armutsbegriff der OCD
nämlich jeder der der
also weniger als 60% des vermieteren
Einkommen
eine völlig Abgeordnete Definition
angetreten und auf die sollte man nicht
abfahren wir sind angeklagt
Abstandsgebot
Menschen an ich bin dafür und auch
wirklich dass niemand hungern soll
niemand frieren soll niemand niemand Not
leiden soll und alle eine vernünftige
Wohnung haben sollen ich bin dafür dass
Hartz IV Empfänger welche Kinder haben
so viel Geld haben für ihre Kinder dass
sie diese Kinder vernünftig anziehen und
würdig zur Schule schicken können ich
bin allerdings auch dafür dass man die
Probleme deutlich anspricht und das und
es geht gar nicht anders wenn man wenn
man das das da wenn man nach Neukölln
geht eben in zahlreichen in zahlreichen
Klassen da die Hälfte der Kinder ohne
Frühstück in die Schule kommt nicht weil
die Eltern nicht das Geld hätten sondern
weil die Eltern zu faul sind aufzustehen
und das Frühstück zu machen das heißt
wir können die Frage des Umfangs von von
Hartz IV für erwerbsfähige nicht trennen
von den sozialen Verhältnissen wir
können Sie auch nicht sprechen von der
Frage dass diese Gruppe eben auch
teilweise bestimmte Defizite bestimmte
persönliche oder der Bildungsdefizite
hat da muss man immer arbeiten da muss
man vor allen Dingen daran arbeiten
irgendwas für die Kinder tut nachdem bei
den Eltern ist es schwer dann haben wir
die nächste Frage haben wir dieses
Lohnabstandsgebot
kommen
Frage ist doch warum sind wir als
Bundesrepublik heute so viel reicher mit
viel mehr Bildungsangeboten mit viel
mehr was auch immer ja wir sind ja
gewachsen da muss als Gesellschaft
entwickelt und haben trotzdem dieses
Problem der Chancen Ungerechtigkeit in
verschärfter Form und eine Ungleichheit
die wir dann alle Lösungen wir sind uns
von Tatsachen so und und deswegen haben
wir das Problem deswegen
schreiben bildet doch nur ein
gesellschaftliches Problem habe dass wir
nicht lösen können nämlich dass wir sehr
viele Leute haben die sagen
aber dann sage ich Ihnen wie wir es
lösen was ich sagen will ist es gibt
offensichtlich sehr viele Jobs die
keiner machen will ja die weil sie auch
am Rande der Unzumutbarkeit sind
deswegen beschreiben Sie das Problem und
wir haben dieses Problem aber wir zeigen
euch jetzt mal jetzt Frage ist es denn
zumutbar dass die Steuerzahler für
jemanden
Berufe und zumutbar ist aufpassen dass
wir gewisse Dinge nicht durcheinander
bringen also erstmal gibt es Menschen
die sind in Hartz IV weil es einfach
persönliches Schicksale sind und das ist
ganz bedauerlich und die verdienen die
Unterstützung und es gibt Menschen die
in Hartz IV sind und beispielsweise
nebenbei noch arbeiten also offenbar
arbeiten können die sich das als
Hängematte schön bequem gemacht haben
und bei den Menschen kann man doch nicht
sagen es gibt Jobs die uns zumutbar sind
die gibt es in Deutschland nicht da wird
es genug Schutz geben Sie wissen das
ganz genau Arbeitsschutz alles und so
weiter und so fort das sind zum Teil
nicht Jobs die
vergnügungssteuerpflichtig sind das mag
sein aber was ist denn bitte an einem
Job wenn man Kellen hat besonders
schlimm das ist ein Job der Spaß macht
dann macht man anderen Menschen Freude
dass der anstrengend ist keine Frage es
gibt ganz ganz viele Jobs in diesem Land
die anstrengend sind der Punkt ist der
das ganz ganz viele Menschen sich
täglich anstrengen und denjenigen etwas
zahlen die sich nicht anstrengen und die
einfach sagen mir ist das eigentlich zu
doof morgens aufzustehen 3 Uhr zum
Bäcker und das ist immer zu blöd das ist
doch der Punkt lassen Sie uns das bitte
von der Seite diskutieren denn alles
nichts anderes unsozial so wie sie
argumentieren ist es unsozial ich habe
gesagt die soziale also sozial wäre auf
jeden Fall dass wir die Industrie nicht
industrialisieren weil nur wenn wir Jobs
haben können wir angemessene
Arbeitswerte zu schaffen das war immer
so wie wir das in dieser Bundesrepublik
verhandelt haben und dann sind wir
eigentlich so billiger beim ersten Thema
ja warum wir jetzt so großartig die sind
industrialisieren aber wenn wir das
alles einpreisen also Algorithmen und so
weiter digitalisieren das heißt dass
sich die Jobs extrem auch verändern dass
wir die ganzen Roboter Algorithmen
aktuell haben wir diese Jobs also wir
haben wirklich eine es gibt auch wir
haben einen Höchststand eigentlich im
Fass in der jobvergabe aber es scheint
ja nicht ja dass die Leute die bei Hartz
IV sind sei seit dass sie krank sind
dass sie vielleicht mit 60 nicht kennen
können was auch immer nein
zu akzeptieren dass alle die auf Hartz
IV sind in der das haben sie eben
Unterschieden ja aber dass das nur die
Hängematte ist weil man nicht anders
kann ich glaube wir müssen ganz anders
ansetzen
für Hartz IV abgeschafft wurden ich
glaube erstmal dass wir uns langsam da
hineindenken müssen dass wir jetzt von
der Industriegesellschaft
ja oder nein das ist eine einfache Frage
ich bin dafür dass wir darüber
nachdenken was ist eigentlich der
Arbeitsbegriff morgen ich bin dafür dass
sie für die abschaffenheit Sanktionen
für die Abschaffung verhindern dass
Hartz IV missbraucht wird oder wollen
wir es nicht verhindern ich glaube dass
der Missbrauch von Hartz IV nicht in
diesen Dimensionen ist wir diskutiert
wird weil das auch immer so ein
echo4-thema ist ja die Arbeit nicht da
sind die Frauen und so weiter wenn man
sich die Zahlen genauer anguckt sind es
ganz viele Leute die einfach nicht an
das können die wir über verschiedene
gesellschaftliche Prozesse in diese
Situation getrieben haben dass die da
sind ist sehr bedauerlich aber ich
weigere mich diesen pauschalen Vorteil
zu machen dass das einfach die faulen
sind wir müssen die zum Arbeiten
gekommen ich glaube wir haben große
gesellschaftliche Probleme wie man eine
Gesellschaft in dieser Runde hat
pauschal geurteilt im Gegenteil herr
Schäfer hat auch sehr differenziert das
aufgesplittet aber wir kommen nicht drum
herum einfach festzustellen das ist man
dass man fast sagen kann diese 70 eure
Wohlstand in unserem Land haben dazu
geführt dass selbst die Sozialleistungen
zu viel geworden sind und damit ein
anderes andere Dinge
und dieser an dass wir quasi immer mehr
Menschen haben die in Abhängigkeit vom
Staat leben und nicht mehr
Eigeninitiative entwickeln und das auch
über Generationen hinweg das ist ein
wachsendes Problem vor allen Dingen in
Großstädten und dieses Problem wird
nicht dadurch gelöst dass wir die
Sozialleistungen erhöhen sondern nur
indem wir sie absenken indem wir den
Anreiz schaffen gerade auch für junge
Leute dass sie ihren ersten Job
aufnehmen ich möchte Ihnen ich habe ich
habe Kinder auch jenseits der 20 ich
auch gebannt mir gar nicht vorstellen
was was los wäre wenn mein wenn mein
21-jähriger irgendwie vom Staat
angeboten bekommt du brauchst überhaupt
nichts tun und bekommst dasselbe Geld
oder sogar doch doch genau darum geht es
wir sind die Frage nämlich
Transformation kommen sie Menschen und
wir bekommen sie junge Leute dazu dass
sie Anstrengung auf sich nehmen und die
Verantwortung für ihr Leben selbst
tragen und das bekommen sie nicht indem
sie ihnen sagen wenn du nicht arbeiten
willst oder wenn das unter deiner Würde
ist weil du meinst du müsstest was hören
dann dann nimmst du eben
Sozialleistungen davon redet doch
niemand das wir reden davon dass
inzwischen in einen Summen Bereich wo es
sich schlicht nicht mehr lohnt arbeiten
zu gehen und wo diese Rechnung immer
mehr Menschen aufmachen dass sie sagen
ich bin doch nicht blöd warum soll ich
das machen ich mache lieber schwarz noch
etwas nebenher habe am Schluss am Ende
des Monats mehr das ist eine gängige
Rechnung und Sie können nicht sozusagen
nur vom guten des Menschen ausgehen
sondern die Menschen recht aber jedes
andere nehmen mit was man was wir ihnen
geben und wenn Sie einen Anreiz setzen
wollen dass die Menschen sich selber
versorgen dann geht das eben nur mit
weniger Sozialleistung Detail bei Ihnen
trotzdem reden wir über ganz andere
Dinge wir reden über eine kolossale
Umformung der Gesellschaft über
Transformationsprozesse gegeben
ja aber die Frage ist welche Jobs sind
dann noch da wer ist qualifiziert für
diesen Jobs und was kann man mit diesem
Fragen die Bildung Realität und fragen
wie ist eigentlich der ökonomische
Unterbau in der Gesellschaft von morgen
in der wir leben wollen und dann müssen
wir uns doch auch mal verabschieden von
klassischen Modellen klassischen
Begriffen von